i feel like i'm part of the circus
troupe that like you know you're part of
a show and you become this intimate
dysfunctional family and then it ends
and then you move on to the next troupe
of people and you become you know tight
as thieves and then that so this that
constantly messes with your head because
you're embedding with different troops
all along the way and then you're like i
got ptsd i don't even know which way is
up i don't know who my real friends are
are you i have my family
it's like summer camp right yeah like i
i
you know i mean and me and justin kirk
this lead were hanging out all the time
and we would smoke cigarettes and it's
like brothers it looked yeah it looked
like we were going to be friends for
life
i haven't seen him since what is it
about the human condition though where
you can be so close in that setting and
then kind of just walk away from each
other and then without contact anymore
like what does that say about like us
well that's the flawed
upbringing part you know you think so
it's it's satisfying for a period of
time yeah and then you can walk away
from it so you're in control of it it's
finite you never get to that next deeper
level where people can call you out on
your [ __ ] you're still being polite
you're still like oh hi
all the good stuff without the heavy
deep dark uglies right wow i never could
be something for that period of time
yeah because
the people that i were on when i was on
mad tv
right because i was on that show for so
long with so many people obviously you
get to know people and you see those
ugly parts you become more
enmeshed and more emotionally
like you know tomorrow we're going to go
jordan invited us to the nope premiere
because i was on mac tv with jordan and
we were on it for so long together that
like there's still there is
a brotherly thing there but like you
know animal practice only lasted
uh 13 episodes yeah and you're there and
you just never get to that point of that
connection i think you're right about
that that's very interesting i want to i
like i want to ponder about that bring
it to your trauma therapy
you know like when i when i do hear his
stories about projects he's done it's
like anything that he was a part of for
three four months is like remains a
fantasy bubble like everything was
perfect the people were great because
they never really yeah and then when you
explained mad tv because you were on it
for you know so freaking long you only
tell me wow
horror
yeah it was terrible like my worst
experiences in life
is in that time period but
i would never change it for the world
because it was
[ __ ] great i was young and um i
didn't know the rules that's why i
farted on people and
i got in trouble i was i was fired oh of
course
i farted in crystal flanagan's mouth and
she cried
it was her first day of work and she was
a regular and
she wanted to quit the show because i
farted in her mouth and wait while she
was eating yogurt while she was eating
yogurt and then another actor attacked
me
and um
and i went home i was like what was so
bad about that you know i mean but it's
supposed to be funny and that was funny
right
it's like do you ever wonder why then
they kept koreans out of showbiz for
something it was you you were the
cadillac you were the president you said
a precedent you think so yeah you [ __ ]
it up for a lot of people bobby yeah
oh my god but because
i feel like the rules changed a little
bit you don't think dick lesuchi was
like hey we cannot have koreans in any
other project
because i pooed in the executive
producer's office yeah you what keep in
mind he was on drugs as well i was on
drugstore okay but i took a poop i took
a poo into the middle of his office but
my point is
[Laughter]
yeah but i would behave in that way and
i in retrospect i go
what the [ __ ] was i doing but you know
at the time you know i
was young
and i was wild but imagine like just
dick lesuchi right thinking like um like
we gave this asian boy a chance
and he looked like [ __ ] all over it all
over my office
not all over it was like three pellets
concentrated it was a concentrated poo
yeah and it was funny at the time
because there was other action did he
laugh no he go he goes cleaning that up
right now
yeah but uh i apologize because later he
became my show runner i had a pilot for
comedy central and he became my
showrunner oh wow yeah so you know it's
not it wasn't a dead it wasn't i didn't
destroy it so you healed uh
but it's really
interesting so um how do you think
easter sunday is going to do
i hope it's huger than a big fat greek
wedding it's gonna i keep saying big fat
greek wedding for filipino people i
think it's gonna be i mean like how long
i mean we never know you never know
nobody knew what wayne's world was when
it came out you know i i know
i know how easter songs are gonna do i
already know too i did too so you have
150 million filipino people worldwide
please just have never seen anything
that's why i went to church and did a
novena today